pierre berthelot chercheur associé à
l'institut prospective et sécurité en
europe
directeur de la revue orient
stratégiques dont jean pierre berthelot
et merci d'être en direct avec nous sur
rt france alors cet ultimatum iranien
qui est à la fois diplomatique et
nucléaire va t'il convainc ou freiner
joe biden à votre avis de prime abord on
peut considérer que c'est quelque chose
qui va plutôt freiner les ardeurs
américaine ou la bonne volonté de byden
de reprendre cet accord avec souvent
d'ailleurs les mêmes négociateurs qui
était à l'époque de pâma maintenant il
est certain que du point de vue iranien
on cherche à faire monter les enchères
pour justement avoir des garanties
solides sur le respect des engagements
américains donc pour l'instant je ne
sais pas s'ils ont bien chacun compris
la logique respectives des deux
protagonistes
justement les autorités iraniennes qui
se disent prêtes à respecter l'accord à
condition que la maison blanche montre
qu'elle est un partenaire fiable
est-ce que la confiance peut être
rétabli entre les deux puissances je
pense que oui la confiance buzz parce
que bon je pense quand même les iraniens
font la part des choses et ils se
rendent compte que buydens n'est pas
trois comme on dit ça c'est une première
chose même s'ils se font pas non plus
forcément d'illusions notoire parce que
le congrès continuera à jouer un rôle
majeur et ce congrès il n'est pas
forcément partisans de l'iran
comme vous le savez même parmi les
démocrates il y en a qui sont partisans
d'une méthode plutôt dur avec l'iran
sont pas tous des colons comme on dit
donc je pense qu'il ya cette conscience
prise de conscience iranienne que les
deux administrations sont différentes
mais elles ne sont pas fondamentalement
différent
donc c'est pour ça que ils veulent des
conditions de garantie beaucoup plus
strictes ils ne sont pas certains que
cela effectivement puissent être
respectées je vous rappelle que même si
aujourd'hui bailon d'un cheveu l'a
emporté au sénat enfin emporté il ya
cinquante autant de sénateurs
républicain que démocrate je vous
rappelle que dans deux ans il y aura les
les élections ni mandat et on peut
imaginer que au bout de deux ans on
arrive enfin à signer un accord et
qu'ils soient remises en cause par
finalement une nouvelle chambre qui
serait hostile à baden c'est ce qui
s'était passé sous clinton dont bill
clinton qui vous rappeler avait été élu
président états unis fin 1992 et qui
deux ans plus tard fait face à une vague
d'ultrabooks hervas trice à la chambre
des représentants qui la mène
effectivement à durcir
par exemple les conditions des relations
avec l'iran donc voilà instant via une
prudence je pense de part et d'autre
même s'il ya une volonté d'aller de
l'avant
alors on l'a bien compris la marge de
manoeuvre de joe biden par rapport au
congrès est assez restreinte on va dire
mais qu'en est il avec ses rapports à
israël et l'arabie saoudite sur ce
dossier iranien
alors effectivement il ya deux autres
comment dire protagoniste important dans
ce dossier l'iran parce que c'est un
état qui a montré ces dernières années
qu'il était prêt à mettre en place le
maximum de moyens pour contrer ce qu'ils
considèrent comme la présence iranienne
et d'ailleurs si on n'arrive pas à un
accord et que le
l'iran se dote de l'arme nucléaire on
sait que les saoudiens iront vers ce
chemin donc
donc il faut tenir compte des irani des
saoudiens sauf que alors qu'ils
n'étaient plus assez belliciste sous
l'époque trump on sait que ils vont être
tenues en commandite à la marge si je
puis dire par les démocrates
parce que il ya la question des droits
de l'homme donc c'est vrai que là la
capacité finalement d'influents ce salon
diène sera peut-être moins de puissants
moins forte que celle là de l'époque de
treuil il y avait des relations
privilégiées avec notamment jared
kushner et mbs
on voit que le qatar de récemment par
d'un dialogue nécessaire avec l'iran et
ces pays se sont réconciliés avec le
qatar ou partiellement donc peut-être on
va suivre une ligne plus qatari comme on
dit une ligne saoudienne donc ça c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour avancer
et puis quand à israël de bien on voit
qu'il ya des critiques qui apparaissent
bon discrètement mais tout de même sur
l'apd est la dénomination du nouvel
ambassadeur qui pourrait prendre sa
place en israël qui pourrait être
également ambassadeur on dit dans les
territoires palestiniens au cac iliad
est peut-être un changement sémantique
qui augurent aussi peut-être d'une
moindre d'un moindre a nié alignement ou
d'un moindre rapprochement
comme il était à l'époque de
l'administration trump merci beaucoup à
pierre berthelot d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin je rappelle que vous
êtes chercheur associé à l'ipp ceux
également directeur de la revue orient
stratégique